in the dark on a Liverpool Street these
were the moments that were to lead to
tragedy Thomas Cashman marked by police
with a blue dot pursuing his intended
victim a man called Joseph knee marked
here in red
the gunfire recorded on a security
camera and shown to the jury it was the
next shot that was to prove fatal to a
young girl
Olivia Pratt Corbell was just nine years
old a unique chatty nosy little girl her
family said Who Loved life and all it
had to offer it was a life cut short by
a gunman who'd gone out to kill
a jury deciding that that gunman was
Cashman whose ruthless Pursuit took the
shooting inside Olivia's home
what Olivia's mother Cheryl made of the
verdict was clear to see as she left
court she and her family sat through the
trial for them and for police a moment
of relief
the circumstances around it were just
abundance and she was cowering behind
them all because she was scared in her
own home
he always feel as though you're safe in
your own house
I think as an investigation team we
could not believe
that the government would continue to
shoot into the house
I don't think we've ever seen anything
like that before
the community had been discourted
by his actions
they've been in fear of him for a long
long time
he will know himself
and have to carry that responsibility
Olivia's mummy Cheryl was injured by the
bullet that killed her daughter the jury
heard her description of that night the
moment she knew Olivia in her words was
gone
this was that intended target that night
convicted burglar knee police say it was
a petty dispute
on suspicion America Cashman had denied
being the gunman he said he was going
about his business as a high-level
cannabis dealer that night but the trial
heard from a witness who said he'd gone
to her home after the shooting looking
for a change of clothes and admitting
having done Joey knee police have
commended her bravery in coming forward
at no time police say as Cashman shown
any remorse is a coward he's despicable
he made great play in the in the trial
that he is a dad
and yet he's put Olivia's family through
this trial I hope he reflects every
morning when he wakes up behind bars and
every night when he goes to sleep
about what he's put Olivia's family
through
the guns used that might have still not
been recovered police say this
investigation continues even after a
lengthy and complex prosecution we're
only a small wheel in the Cog here of
you know nothing will bring Olivia back
this is just for the family some sense
of justice the person who ruined their
lives is nicely
you know we've not got Justice for them
Cashman was driven away from court but
will be back there on Monday to be
sentenced police say Olivia's death
should not be in vain a girl of wit and
kindness her family said whose life was
short but whose personality certainly
wasn't